gets past caldwell-pope gets inside
kicks it out back up top the Gordon
little fake one dribble sets fires
that's a three-point game the one minute
to go in his game and three members of
their bench in double figures all right
step back three four step back off the
ball they find Gordon Gordon puts up a
three and get Mike D'Antoni credit use
harden as a decoy to bring Gordon back
off and because he was faced up they
didn't want to risk the foul on the
catch Thornton with his fourth
three-pointer to tie the game and forced
the extra five minutes
home will hook right there on him yeah
but that's also the problem with Ingram
putting his back to the bat his man five
minutes home we'll hook right there on
him yeah but that's also the problem
with Ingram putting his back to the bat
his man it makes the inbounds pass he
can put it right on the month clutch
shot kicks it back out to Tucker up time
rivers Gordon's gonna try another break
cuts it in
and the first lead of the game for the
Houston Rockets Hart brings it back out
called wolf wolf gets right up into him
harden the step-back debris
[Applause]